il est il est assez mal venu de la part
du président de la République qui a
quand même été élu et réélu en appelant
les Français à faire barrage à l'extrême
droite
je sens cette diabolisation
sur Macron ne serait pas président de la
République donc venir maintenant que il
n'est plus rééligible
nous dire que après lui finalement le
déluge je trouve ça extrêmement malsain
de sa part je trouve que c'est un
cynisme assez assez incroyable il a fait
la diabolisation et maintenant il va
nous faire la banalisation du
rassemblement du rassemblement national
pour vous ce propos ne vise ne vise rien
d'autre alors sur le sujet on pourrait
être disserter longtemps je pense que
évidemment les gens qui votent pour le
rassemblement national aujourd'hui sont
très très loin très très loin de cette
de cette histoire
voilà ne connaissent pas les fondateurs
du du Front national moi j'oublie pas
parce que je pense que il y a des
moments de l'histoire qui sont qui sont
révélateur j'oublie pas que dans les
fondateurs du rassemblement national il
y a quelqu'un comme Pierre Bousquet qui
a porté l'uniforme qui a été un officier
de la de la de la vaffenesse pendant
deux ans
enfin voilà
et l'héritier de Pétain aujourd'hui non
aujourd'hui rassemblement national je
sais plus exactement ce que c'est
bon enfin force de ce souvenir ils ont
fait alors 50 ans que dans les
fondateurs du rassemblement national du
Front national aujourd'hui vous tapez
Front national sur Google ça n'existe
plus vous tombez sur rassemblement
national directement et donc dans les
dans les fondateurs de ce parti il y a
des gens qui ont porté l'uniforme SS
voilà moi type personnel c'est une
une lignée dans laquelle j'aurais un peu
de mal à m'inscrire je suis gaulliste et
le vrai d'ailleurs point commun dans
l'histoire du Front national ou
rassemblement national c'est
l'antigolisme ça c'est sûr on va parler
de comment en commission des affaires
sociales l'étude de la proposition de
loi Eliott qui vise à abroger la réforme
des retraites
quelle sera la position des députés LR
ce matin en commission
on verra je ne suis pas membre de cette
commission des affaires sociales donc
leur vote discutait avec eux je pense
que je pense que la majorité soutenait
la nécessité d'une réforme de retraite
et
se prêtera pas ce qui en réalité quand
même au fond une espèce de de facétie
parce que chacun sait ce texte ne
pourrait pas adopter au Sénat et donc
c'est un coup un coup pour rien c'est
l'occasion c'est l'occasion pour
Monsieur de charles Blé de Courson de
faire un peu de de buzz mais tout ça
n'about rien donc faire croire aux
Français
faire croire en français que ça pourrait
être débouché sur quelque chose
ça sert pas à grand chose bon après on a
le droit de mener les combats les
combats qu'on veut moi ce qui me ce qui
me stupéfait chaque jour quand j'entends
parler de la retraite c'est que plus
personne dans ce pays ne parle de la
situation des retraités on a
l'impression que les retraités doivent
être devenu des des nanties que tout va
très bien qu'il y a plus de retraités
pauvres dans notre pays enfin la réforme
des retraites elle est d'abord faite
pour eux pour qu'on retrouve une
capacité demain mais ça va arriver
d'ailleurs très vite à augmenter on
s'est battu nous les républicains pour
qu'il revalorisation des de 1,8 millions
de retraite les plus modestes dès la fin
de cette année c'est c'est ça l'enjeu de
la vendeur de plus personne n'en parle
tout le monde s'en fiche non mais
qu'est-ce que du coup qu'est-ce que vous
allez faire aujourd'hui est-ce que vous
allez tenter de torpiller ce texte avec
la majorité pour qu'il n'y ait pas de
débat le 8 juin
est-ce qu'il faut qu'il y a un débat le
8 juin ce qu'il faut qu'il y ait un vote
le 8 juin respectons la procédure
parlementaire il y a un débat en
commission il y aura un vote en
commission on verra quel texte sort de
la Commission vous n'avez donné aucune
consigne de vote à vos députés qui siège
au sein de la au sein de retraite
l'histoire a montré qu'il fallait un
tout petit peu d'humidité et que les
consignes ne suffisait pas toujours
voilà
il y avait ceux qui de toute façon sont
contre cette
pardon
il y a ceux qui parce qu'ils étaient
pour la réforme et il y a ceux qui
considèrent que de toute façon même
s'ils étaient contre la réforme des
retraites considère que ce texte est un
coup d'épée dans l'eau ça sert à rien et
que il y a un moment faut pas non plus
tromper les Français faire croire que
qui peut sortir quelque chose de ce test
musicale au sein de votre groupe les
députés qui avaient voté pour la motion
de censure ou que c'était abstenu il y a
quelques semaines ont été remplacés
aussi sur les finances
[Musique]
toutes les semaines dans toutes les
commissions dès lors qu'il y a des il y
a des votes un peu importants on
remplace on remplace des députés chaque
groupe de la France insoumise ils ont
été très discret mais à remplacer 5 5
députés au sein de la commission des des
affaires sociales aujourd'hui je pense
que tous les goûts je pense que tous les
groupes pardon je pense que tous les
groupes ont remplacer les députés vous
imaginez bien qu'un député ne se fait
pas débrancher de fisc comme ça donc
il y a pas de sujet de de ce côté-là
de la France insoumise et ricocal il a
déclaré la proposition de l'alliotte
recevable hier pour vous c'est une
décision politique ou c'est une décision
justifiée
un peu politique j'avais l'article 42 de
la Constitution il est il est très clair
après il y a des usages qui sont
différents
traditions parlementaires on est un peu
plus souple sur les PPL que sur les
amendements qui en décharge sur les
propositions de loi le fait avec qui a
depuis 2009 qui a un président de la
règlement a changé etc et que la
présence de la commission des finances
revient à l'opposition et que même lui
je crois huit PPL qui n'ont pas été
examinés en toute ou partie qui ont été
censurés parce qu'elles elles
aggravaient les charges publics
en droit j'ai un peu de mal à partager
son analyse oui alors lui en politique
je pense qu'il a agi que même de façon
un peu politique dans cette affaire
voilà alors après ça va se débat il faut
aussi faire attention à respecter les
droits du des droits du Parlement dans
une situation totalement inédite où
jusqu'à présent en fait tout ça n'avait
pas de valeur de laisser venir des PPL
dans les dans les niches de position ça
n'avait pas d'importance il y avait pas
d'enjeu aujourd'hui si on a un peu plus
comme il y a plus de majorité pour les
pour les pour les bloquer
évidemment le le il y a un peu plus de
de risques entre guillemets pour
respecter les droits
le risque qu'on court désormais je parle
de de risques en terme juridique c'est
de laisser voter des textes qui seront
censurés après par le Conseil
constitutionnel parce qu'ils aggravent
des charges qui sont contraires et donc
c'est pas la peine
de tromper une fois encore les Français
en votant au Parlement des choses dont
on sait tous pertinemment qu'en réalité
elles seront censurées si jamais elles
étaient votées c'est une argumentation
lui dit certaines propositions de loi
sont passées en étant aussi malgajé que
la prophétisation
bien vieillir par exemple qui ont été
gagés de la même manière sur les taxes
pour le tabac et elles n'ont pas été
censurées au départ pourquoi celle-là
fallait-il quelque chose absolument sur
les retraites en 2009 du temps de de
Didier
c'est pour ça que c'est une question de
jurisprudence c'est pour ça que moi je
voilà je suis assez personnel assez
ouvert sur le sujet je pense qu'il faut
faire preuve d'une certaine d'une
certaine souplesse même si il faut quand
même être un peu honnête et se rendre
compte des conséquences de tout ça et
notamment on peut pas faire croire qu'il
y a pas de sujets de constitutionnalité
et que si un texte venait un jour à être
voté alors qu'on sait pertinemment qu'il
crée une charge et bien il serait
forcément annulé donc alors on n'est pas
là pour faire semblant on est là pour
voter des lois qui ont une chance
prospérer est-ce que du coup ça veut
dire que vous allez contribuer à la
suppression de l'article premier et de
ce texte qui abroge la retraite la
majorité des députés de mon groupe
voteront la suppression de cet article
bien sûr en cohérence avec ce qui était
leur position et vous soutiendrez il y a
LeBron Pivet si jamais elle active
l'article 40 en séance la semaine
prochaine elle aura raison de le faire
ou pas si si le texte sur l'article
premier était supprimé elle aurait plus
besoin de le faire
ce sera la spécialité de Monsieur
Coquerel d'abord est-ce que vous
entendez l'opposition qui dit que s'il y
a pas de débat s'il y a pas de vote il y
a risque d'une crise institutionnelle et
démocratique majeure
on peut pas on peut pas dire qu'il y a
pas eu de qui a pas eu de débats il y a
pas eu de débat d'ailleurs c'est
étonnant ce sont ceux qui ont fait en
sorte qu'il y ait pas de débat qui
disent qu'il y a pas de débat c'est
quand même assez stupéfiant un tout
petit peu de bonne foi aussi dans la vie
politique il y a plein de sujets moi
dont j'aurais aimé qu'on discute dans la
réforme de retraite la pénibilité on en
a pas parlé pourquoi parce que la France
insoumise à bloquer le travail le
travail parlementaire avec des milliers
et des milliers d'amendements
sur ce point-là
ils ont tout fait pour qu'on n'arrive
pas au vote sur l'article 7 il y a un
moment dans le débat qui était celui qui
portait à l'âge le rapport de l'âge
légal ou plusieurs groupes y compris de
la nups ont retiré des amendements pour
qu'on accélère la France insoumise est
restée bloquée ne voulait surtout pas de
vote mais souvenez-vous de l'histoire
quand même on peut pas la réécrire comme
ça ils ne vont pas dans d'autres qui ne
voulait pas de vote après notre
Constitution prévoit qu'à un moment
le 49-3 c'est pas non plus totalement
c'est pas la solution idéale mais c'est
pas non plus totalement une forfaiture
chacun est face à ces responsabilité de
la forme des retraites est-ce que
c'était pas l'occasion justement l'étude
de ce texte qu'il y ait un vote tous les
ans sur le sujet soyons soyons un tout
petit peu sérieux quoi je dirais c'est
une fois encore c'est pas ceux qui ont
empêché une réforme de retraite au
passage à compter d'histoire c'est
toujours un moment un moment douloureux
Nicolas Sarkozy qui avait fait un peu
plus de concertation de 1009 avec le
même but de millions de personnes dans
la rue donc tous les gens qui me disent
évidemment ils ont été très mauvais en
méthode évidemment tu sais été très
incohérent vis-à-vis pour les Français
avec un président de la République
Emmanuel Macron qui expliquait il y a
trois ans imaginez pas à faire
travailler les gens à 64 ans etc etc bon
tout ça était on aurait pu faire
effectivement je pense un peu mieux en
termes de concertation voir beaucoup
mieux c'est une litote je pense que ça
n'aurait pas empêché qui est des
manifestations et une voilà une
mobilisation sociale assez vive vous qui
connaissez bien votre groupe combien de
députés les républicains sont prêts à
voter cette proposition de l'ayotte
strictement rien on en est pas là et on
verra la semaine prochaine ce qui sort
de la de la Commission
monsieur plancher qui était qui est le
président du groupe yote qui était à
votre place hier il fait planer la
menace d'une motion de censure si jamais
il n'y a pas de débat s'il y a pas de
vote vous c'est justifié pour vous non
il y a un moment je trouve que ce pays
avance où est-ce qu'on est décidé une
fois encore j'avais ça très forme de
retraite elle est aussi faite pour les
retraités ou c'est le premier incident
qu'on a eu dans cette Assemblée
nationale élu ça a été quand il y a eu
un amendement de monsieur de Courson
pour aller quand même incroyable
monsieur de Courson pour aller piquer
400 millions d'euros sur le budget dans
un combattant pour augmenter les petites
retraites qu'il était pas ce qui n'était
pas assez revalorisés et aujourd'hui
plus personne n'en parle des retraités
modestes moi ce que je trouve le plus le
plus les situations les plus
douloureuses auxquelles je vais faire
face aux député dans ma circonscription
c'est des gens très âgés à la retraite
qui ne s'en sortent plus voilà et qui me
disent je vais pas me remettre à
travailler avec 90 ans et ça j'aimerais
qu'on se souvienne que cette situation
elle existe et que la réforme des
retraites elle est faite pour remédier
un peu à cette situation
qui vous concerne en ce moment le projet
immigration qui est étudiée en ce moment
Gérald Darmanin où on est de vous de
vous discussions il a semblé vous tendre
la main à plusieurs reprises on a du mal
à comprendre les positions des LRS
nous on a mis une déposition sur la
table qui sont très claires un projet de
l'ordinaire un projet de loi
constitutionnel ce qui est
incompréhensible c'est la position du
gouvernement vous avez monsieur Darmanin
qui vous explique un jour que il fait un
texte pour dire sur l'immigration et
vous avez Olivier Véran porte-parole du
gouvernement j'ai pas n'importe qui qui
va au Danemark pour dire non non non
regardez un texte trop dur sur
l'immigration c'est pas possible vous
avez la première ministre qui dit non
non on touchera pas à la Constitution et
Darmanin qui dit oui touche à la
constitution pourquoi pas mais ça dépend
pas de moi ouais sincèrement donc on a
des propositions on les a mis sur la
table et on peut les les envoyer et
aller le porter à pied à cheval comme il
veut à Monsieur Darmanin pour qu'il en
prenne connaissance et nous on a trouvé
ça on attend ensemble on attendra de
savoir ce qui est la position du
gouvernement voilà ce qui est la
position du Grand moi je ne la comprends
pas en matière d'immigration on peut pas
avoir plus d'immigration et moins
d'immigration en même temps ça n'existe
pas il faut qu'il choisisse un certain
nombre de vos demandes quand même sur le
conditionnement des visas l'instauration
des des côtés annuels d'immigration
c'est pas possible évidemment je sais
pas c'est pas complet notre projet il
est pas là nous on a mis deux textes sur
la sur la table
en fait c'est quoi ce de texte en un mot
le premier c'est
proposition de loi ordinaire c'est pour
aller au plus loin possible à droit à
droite constitutionnel et convention
internationale constante et le deuxième
texte c'est c'est adapter notre notre
droit constitutionnel pour se protéger
un peu plus des jurisprudences de la
cioth ce qu'il faut que les Français
comprennent c'est que aujourd'hui
l'Assemblée nationale est Sénat peuvent
voter une loi on va dire d'immigration
elle peut être considérée comme conforme
à la Constitution par le Conseil
émotionnel et dès le lendemain dès le
lendemain des juges chargés d'appliquer
la loi en France peuvent s'asseoir sur
cette loi
au nom de la jurisprudence de la Cour
Européenne des droites c'est totalement
incompréhensible pour les Françaises ça
caractérise l'impuissance politique dans
ce pays donc c'est pour ça qu'on pense
qu'il faut aussi changer notre
Constitution moi je n'ai pas de réponse
de la part du gouvernement et d'avoir de
la majorité sur sur ce sujet là il
pas du tout de discussion qui ont été
entamées parce qu'Elizabeth Bank ça fait
quelques semaines qu'elle a demandé
Gérald darbonne
pourquoi est-ce qu'on a pris cette
initiative de mettre nos textes sur la
table mais parce que ça fait un an que
le gouvernement balade tout le monde
avec ses histoires de texte sur
l'immigration qui est devenu une espèce
de texte
fantôme
qui a été sur lequel ils ont changé ils
le gouvernement a changé 7 fois de pied
il a été décalé trois ou quatre fois le
président de la République lui-même a
dit on va le saucissonner et puis après
il dit finalement le saucissonnera pas
on y comprend plus rien quoi mais il y a
un moment en fait la réalité c'est quoi
c'est que en matière d'immigration on
peut pas faire de en même temps on peut
pas vouloir plus d'immigration et moins
d'immigration alors c'est ce que nous
propose ce texte par exemple la question
de des régularisations dans les secteurs
en tension pour vous ça reste une ligne
rouge
ce qui est une ligne rouge c'est d'aller
créer un titre de séjour spécifique et
d'annoncer un mouvement de
régularisation
massive par définition de de gens en
situation irrégulière bien sûr c'est une
ligne rouge en réalité si on veut régler
si on veut réaliser la situation des
médias en tension
ponctuellement on peut tout à fait le
faire il y a une loi votez pas il y a
2000-2007 qui qui crée un titre de
séjour qui s'appelle compétences et
compétences et talent qui permet il y a
une liste de métiers en tension on n'a
pas besoin de ce nouveau truc avec une
c'est un appel d'air c'est un appel
d'air que faire le gouvernement mais
pourquoi ils ont rajouté ça dans le
temps il faut quand même monsieur dans
Madame parce que c'est une concession à
l'aile gauche la
majorités
et bien on peut le gouvernement peut
très bien dans tous les départements les
préfets ponctuellement peuvent prendre
en 2021 après 10 ans de de de de silence
le ministère de l'Intérieur a ressorti
cette liste des métiers en tension la
réactualiser donc aujourd'hui ils ont
tous les outils vouloir aller plus loin
c'est juste pour donner un signe à
l'aile gauche la majorité d'ailleurs
c'était très intéressant depuis qu'on a
mis notre proposition sur la table vous
avez
des gens qui des députés de la majorité
qui l'ont dit oui le proposition de
républicains nous sommes va très bien
c'est peut-être parce que je viens de la
droite donc oui ça nous va et puis vous
avez juste à chaoui prison d'acquisition
des lois de l'Assemblée nationale qui a
fait une tribune pour dire hors de
question
c'est pas possible donc il y a une
ambiguïté terrible dans la majorité nous
on ne
que à force de dire alors Gérald
Darmanin a des lignes rouges vous vous
avez des lignes rouges elles sont très
claires est-ce que le résultat ça ne va
pas être qu'il n'y aura aucun texte sur
l'immigration et que ça n'avancera pas
sur le gouvernement de prendre ses
responsabilités ce gouvernement veut
vraiment comme le prétend chez Darmanin
la situation c'est qu'on ne sait pas
quelle est la position du gouvernement
voilà on ne sait pas qui est la position
du gouvernement on ne sait pas ce qu'ils
veulent ce qu'ils ne veulent pas etc
nous avons pesé de manière importante en
modérant le gouvernement voulait aller à
65 ans j'assume d'avoir dit que ça me
paraissait un peu brutal et que fallait
faire seulement 63 ans à la fin du
quinquennat une clause d'envoyeur 64 ans
donc c'est pas le projet on a imposé
qu'une revalorisation des retraités
actuels les plus modestes donc c'est pas
le projet du gouvernement on n'a pas
fait ça pour faire plaisir au
gouvernement on a fait ça par conviction
et là par conviction et bien on dit au
gouvernement qu'on ne votera pas un
texte laxiste en matière d'immigration
par conviction j'ai voté le texte sur le
nucléaire voilà donc on se prononce par
rapport à nos convictions à la
conviction qu'on a de savoir c'est utile
ou pas à l'intérêt du pays un dernier
mot là-dessus parce que dans son
interview Gérald Darmanin à cette phrase
il dit travaillons dans l'intérêt du
pays il y a plein de gens comme
messieurs buffet Retailleau Larcher
sciotique ils sont prêts pas vous
travaillez dans l'intérêt du pays je
pense que je pense que la preuve
je pense que les histoires montrent que
voilà que on n'est pas d'accord avec le
gouvernement sur beaucoup de choses
qu'on est souvent dans le droit de faire
constructif
plus dur en affaire oui ça comme ça je
vais vous travaillez vous parlez que
maintenant pas du tout mais problème je
suis pas sûr que Gérald Darmanin est
vraiment totalement les manettes dans
cette affaire c'est pas lui qui fait les
arbitrages et on sent bien qu'il y a une
qui a dans une le dit lui-même et qui a
une espèce de de division au sein même
du gouvernement entre monsieur Véran et
qui veut surtout pas conduire au système
et Monsieur Darmanin qui veut qu'on est
durcisse si le gouvernement devait
dégainer le 49-3 sur ce texte parce que
vous lui apporteriez pas votre soutien
quel serait la
positionnement voulait passer à
l'Assemblée nationale en force sur un
texte qui
l'axiste qui a grave les choses en
matière d'immigration plutôt que de de
les régler à titre personnel moi je
souhaite qu'on dépose une motion de
censure ça se fait sur lesquels on a pas
le droit
de dormir
que les Français sur ce sujet là
regardez les sondages aujourd'hui les
Français veulent vraiment qui est une
emprise en main veulent qui est de plus
de fermeté on n'a pas le droit de faire
semblant
en ce moment la loi de programmation
[Musique]
à votre ronde on attendra d'être à la
fin du débat en réalité de là encore il
y a beaucoup de communication dans dans
ce texte on nous présente un texte une
nouvelle LPM avec un effort très
important mais l'effort de plus
important ce sera après le quinquennat
de Macron donc ça coûte pas très cher
comme promesse ça
n'engage que ceux qui croient comme
disait un sénateur célèbre
donc c'est pas c'est pas top
on a demandé on avait demandé ensemble
de choses au gouvernement notamment de
de rééquilibrer l'effort de d'anticiper
l'effort la guerre sur le territoire
européen c'est pas c'est pas après 2027
c'est maintenant tous les pays voisins
font un effort de de de défense de
réarmement beaucoup plus important
beaucoup plus massif tout de suite il y
a que la France qui en réalité ne le
fait pas les plus 3 milliards par an que
nous annonce monsieur Lecornu c'est ce
qui était déjà prévu au terme de la
précédente LPM et en réalité on aura
moins de moins de rafales avec LPM en
2030 qu'il était prévu d'en avoir on
aura moins de de griffon véhicules
terrestre pour la matière qu'il était
prévu d'en avoir on met même certaines
de nos industries de défense en
difficulté en reportant ce programme
donc voilà c'est pas votre compte c'est
pas les Français c'est pas les Français
qu'il faut que Monsieur Lecornu
impressionne avec cet effort de défense
c'est pas les Français ce sont nos
potentiels adversaires vous organisez
aujourd'hui à l'Assemblée nationale une
convention sur le logement est-ce que
vous jugez que c'est l'anglement de la
politique d'Emmanuel Macron aujourd'hui
Macron qui a qui considère que l'argent
investit dans l'immobilier c'est
l'argent qui dort on le voit avec sa
réforme de l'impôt sur la fortune
immobilière de l'ISF de nuit fille et
vraiment
c'est pas du tout du tout du tout la
Médée on en a la preuve avec 100000
logements en moins par rapport à ce qui
se faisait une dizaine d'années
aujourd'hui depuis le début de l'année
35% de maisons individuelles en moins
derrière c'est c'est immédiatement des
dizaines de milliers d'emplois qui sont
menacés dans notre pays ce sont aussi
des des milliers de Français qui se
voient refuser des prêts avec la hausse
des taux d'intérêts et qui ne peuvent
pas accéder à ce rêve d'accéder à la
propriété et en fait je me suis Macron
il y a beaucoup dites de logique
là-dessus il sait convertis je crois à
cette idéologie qui fallait à tout prix
faire renoncer les Français alors rêve
de la maison individuelle d'où une
politique très très dur douce zéro
artificialisation qui aujourd'hui bloque
complètement la construction merci
Olivier Marleix merci beaucoup d'avoir
été notre invité ce matin l'une de la
dépêche c'est cette question mort aux
vaches c'est à la Une de votre journal
merci beaucoup Christelle on passe au
club des territoires